I just realized we're probably making history right now. We might be the first ever podcast to be recorded during a road trip while one person's behind the wheel, one person's in the passenger seat. Definitely it's got to be the first tech podcast that's ever done something like this. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 135, recorded on June 18th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we record live from in the car on the 2023 Slovenia road trip. In today's episode, we're recording from Austria. See, we should have been recording earlier. So what's another problem that...
I just realized we're probably making history right now. We might be the first ever podcast to be recorded during a road trip while one person's behind the wheel, one person's in the passenger seat. Definitely it's got to be the first tech podcast that's ever done something like this. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 135, recorded on June 18th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we record live from in the car on the 2023 Slovenia road trip. In today's episode, we're recording from Austria. See, we should have been recording earlier. So what's another problem that...|||我刚意识到，我们现在可能正在创造历史。我们可能是史上第一个在公路旅行中录制的播客，当时一个人在开车，一个人坐在副驾驶座上。这绝对是第一个做这种事的科技播客。欢迎收听 ADSP，第 135 期播客，录制于 2023 年 6 月 18 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）在 2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行的车中进行现场录音。在今天的节目中，我们从奥地利进行录音。你看，我们其实应该早点开始录音的。那么，还有什么问题是……
Wait, is that the start of the episode? Yeah, I mean... Put the mic in front of me. We're here, folks, live in austria is that too loud on the game welcome to the 2023 slovenia road trip we're live on the road i'm behind the wheel we got the ac blasting that's actually not true it's not blasting where are we bryce we're in we are in western austria we're not entirely sure where we are right now because we have no internet signal at the moment. What do you mean? We have no internet? We currently have no internet now.
Wait, is that the start of the episode? Yeah, I mean... Put the mic in front of me. We're here, folks, live in austria is that too loud on the game welcome to the 2023 slovenia road trip we're live on the road i'm behind the wheel we got the ac blasting that's actually not true it's not blasting where are we bryce we're in we are in western austria we're not entirely sure where we are right now because we have no internet signal at the moment. What do you mean? We have no internet? We currently have no internet now.|||等等，这是节目的开始吗？对，我是说……把麦克风放到我面前。各位，我们现在在奥地利现场，这声音在游戏里会不会太大声欢迎来到 2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行，我们在路上进行现场直播，我在开车，我们开着超大的空调，其实这不对，没开那么大，我们在哪儿，布莱斯？我们在……我们在奥地利西部，我们不太确定现在具体在哪儿，因为我们目前没有网络信号。什么意思？我们没有网络？我们现在目前没有网络。
And I think neither of us downloaded offline maps on Google Maps. So we better not hit the little X on your phone. What's this map here then? That's because we started the navigation. First of all, when you're talking, here's Bryce holding the mic in front of my mouth. Man, I'm loud. Man, if we apologize if the audio quality is terrible, Bryce doesn't know what he's doing. I'm the professional where it comes to the hardware.
And I think neither of us downloaded offline maps on Google Maps. So we better not hit the little X on your phone. What's this map here then? That's because we started the navigation. First of all, when you're talking, here's Bryce holding the mic in front of my mouth. Man, I'm loud. Man, if we apologize if the audio quality is terrible, Bryce doesn't know what he's doing. I'm the professional where it comes to the hardware.|||而且我觉得我们两个都没在谷歌地图上下载离线地图。所以我们最好别按你手机上的那个小叉号。那这地图是什么？那是因为我们启动了导航。首先，当你说话时，看布莱斯正把麦克风举在我嘴前。天哪，我的声音真大。天哪，如果音频质量很糟糕，我们向大家道歉，布莱斯根本不知道自己在干什么。在硬件方面我才是专业的。
That is true. But we're somewhere in Austria. We are making our way to the city of Bled where we are going to swim in Lake Bled. The hills are alive with the sound of music.
That is true. But we're somewhere in Austria. We are making our way to the city of Bled where we are going to swim in Lake Bled. The hills are alive with the sound of music.|||确实如此。但我们现在在奥地利的某个地方。我们正前往布莱德市，准备去布莱德湖游泳。群山回荡着音乐之声。
That's where it took place in Austria, right? That is correct. That is correct. We should do a little sing-along. My mother, here's a little anecdote for the listeners. I have three sisters, and my mother thought we were the Von Trapp family when we were kids,
That's where it took place in Austria, right? That is correct. That is correct. We should do a little sing-along. My mother, here's a little anecdote for the listeners. I have three sisters, and my mother thought we were the Von Trapp family when we were kids,|||那是故事发生的地方，对吧？没错。没错。我们应该一起唱一首歌。我母亲，这里给听众讲个小轶事。我有三个姐妹，我母亲小时候以为我们就是冯·特拉普一家，
and so she made us memorize most of the songs to the sound of music, and she would make us sometimes after dinner perform the, you know, Auf Wiedersehen, Goodbye, whatever that is. I apologize for the folks, is that German? I think it's German and you know, so like two of my younger sisters they would do, we flit, we flat say goodbye and anyways
and so she made us memorize most of the songs to the sound of music, and she would make us sometimes after dinner perform the, you know, Auf Wiedersehen, Goodbye, whatever that is. I apologize for the folks, is that German? I think it's German and you know, so like two of my younger sisters they would do, we flit, we flat say goodbye and anyways|||所以她让我们背熟了《音乐之声》里的大部分歌曲，有时晚饭后她会让我们表演那个，你知道的，“Auf Wiedersehen（再见）”、“Goodbye（再见）”，诸如此类的。向大家道歉，那是德语吗？我觉得是德语，你知道的，我两个妹妹会表演，我们飞奔，我们飘过，说再见，总之……
I was I can't remember which role I played, but anyways sound of music, fantastic we love you Austria, but we, Sound of Music, fantastic. We love you, Austria, but we're only driving through you to get to Slovenia. Slovenia, here we come. We got in, Connor got in in the morning yesterday to Austria. I got in around 5 p.m. and didn't get to the hotel until like 6 or 7 because Connor's luggage got lost.
I was I can't remember which role I played, but anyways sound of music, fantastic we love you Austria, but we, Sound of Music, fantastic. We love you, Austria, but we're only driving through you to get to Slovenia. Slovenia, here we come. We got in, Connor got in in the morning yesterday to Austria. I got in around 5 p.m. and didn't get to the hotel until like 6 or 7 because Connor's luggage got lost.|||我当时……我不记得我演的是哪个角色了，但总之《音乐之声》，太棒了，我们爱你奥地利，但是我们，《音乐之声》，太棒了。我们爱你，奥地利，但我们只是开车穿过你，好去斯洛文尼亚。斯洛文尼亚，我们来啦。我们到达了，康纳昨天早上到达奥地利。我大约下午 5 点到达，直到 6、7 点才到酒店，因为康纳的行李丢了。
Oh, yeah. Well you you explain what happened listen folks we've been in europe here for two and a half weeks now we started off in poland we then went to italy lambda days was fantastic uh italian c++ was pretty good and uh and then we went to zurich we went to sw to Switzerland. Oh my God, Switzerland. So beautiful. Uh, the trip has been basically amazing. It's been perfect until, until on route to Vienna, Austria. Uh, the, the wonderful people of Australian, Australian, Austrian airlines, uh, lost my luggage and, uh, I was pretty Zen about it because what is getting upset about something like that do? However, that was all my clothes. Long story short, Bryce ended up with my luggage and brought it to the hotel we were staying at in Vienna. And, uh, I am wearing now my good vibes
Oh, yeah. Well you you explain what happened listen folks we've been in europe here for two and a half weeks now we started off in poland we then went to italy lambda days was fantastic uh italian c++ was pretty good and uh and then we went to zurich we went to sw to Switzerland. Oh my God, Switzerland. So beautiful. Uh, the trip has been basically amazing. It's been perfect until, until on route to Vienna, Austria. Uh, the, the wonderful people of Australian, Australian, Austrian airlines, uh, lost my luggage and, uh, I was pretty Zen about it because what is getting upset about something like that do? However, that was all my clothes. Long story short, Bryce ended up with my luggage and brought it to the hotel we were staying at in Vienna. And, uh, I am wearing now my good vibes|||哦，对。那你来解释一下发生了什么。听着，各位，我们在欧洲已经待了两个半星期了。我们从波兰开始，然后去了意大利，Lambda Days 大会太棒了，呃，意大利 C++ 大会也相当不错，然后我们去了苏黎世，我们去了瑞……去了瑞士。天哪，瑞士。太美了。呃，这次旅行基本上棒极了。一直都很完美，直到……直到在去往奥地利维也纳的路上。呃，澳大……澳大利亚航空，哦不，奥地利航空那些可爱的员工弄丢了我的行李，呃，我对这事看得很开，因为为这种事生气的意义何在呢？然而，那是我所有的衣服。长话短说，布莱斯最后拿到了我的行李，把它带到了我们在维也纳住的酒店。而且，呃，我现在穿着我的“好心情”
t-shirt that I bought that Austria airlines will be paying for because I thought I would need to buy clothes. And the Good Vibes t-shirt is our good luck t-shirt. Good vibes, good luck. You know, it's a, I don't know. I don't know what else to say. What do you got to add to the story, Bryce? We should clarify that when Connor says that I ended up with this luggage, what he means is that my flight arrived later and I picked it up from the lost luggage. Not that the airline somehow gave his luggage to me.
t-shirt that I bought that Austria airlines will be paying for because I thought I would need to buy clothes. And the Good Vibes t-shirt is our good luck t-shirt. Good vibes, good luck. You know, it's a, I don't know. I don't know what else to say. What do you got to add to the story, Bryce? We should clarify that when Connor says that I ended up with this luggage, what he means is that my flight arrived later and I picked it up from the lost luggage. Not that the airline somehow gave his luggage to me.|||T恤，是我买的，奥地利航空会报销这笔费用，因为我觉得我得买衣服。而这件“好心情”T恤就是我们的幸运 T 恤。好心情，好运气。你知道，这……我不知道。我不知道还能说些什么。布莱斯，你有什么要补充的吗？我们得澄清一下，当康纳说我拿到了这个行李时，他的意思是我的航班到得晚一些，我从失物招领处把它领了回来。并不是航空公司不知怎么把他的行李错交给了我。
But speaking of Australia. We weren't speaking. That was a slip of the tongue. Yeah. Okay. When my flight from Varna to here, we taxiing on the runway, and I look next to me, and there is a Virgin Australia plane in Bulgaria,
But speaking of Australia. We weren't speaking. That was a slip of the tongue. Yeah. Okay. When my flight from Varna to here, we taxiing on the runway, and I look next to me, and there is a Virgin Australia plane in Bulgaria,|||但说到澳大利亚。我们刚才没在说这个。那是口误。对。好吧。当我搭乘从瓦尔纳飞往这里的航班时，我们在跑道上滑行，我朝旁边一看，保加利亚居然有一架维珍澳大利亚航空的飞机，
and not like a long-distance plane, like a short-distance plane, like an aerobody plane. And I'm like, how did this come to be here? Just to check, you hit the record button, right? I did hit the record button. We are recording. So we had a fascinating conversation about MaxScan and a few other related algorithmic things.
and not like a long-distance plane, like a short-distance plane, like an aerobody plane. And I'm like, how did this come to be here? Just to check, you hit the record button, right? I did hit the record button. We are recording. So we had a fascinating conversation about MaxScan and a few other related algorithmic things.|||而且不是那种长途飞机，而是短途飞机，比如窄体客机。当时我就想，这东西怎么会出现在这里？顺便确认一下，你按了录音键吧？我按了录音键。我们在录音。所以我们刚才进行了一场精彩的对话，关于 MaxScan 以及其他一些相关的算法问题。
But we'd already started driving and we hadn't taken the microphone out, so we didn't record any of it but uh i'm i'm a little fascinated with uh the mac scan and some of the properties of scans of that type and so i think we're going to talk a little bit more about it so the the thing that fascinated me was right uh should we tell the problem first well kind of you've already kind of ruined the solution a little bit uh but you know what we're not going to spoil it well we did spoil it, but so this is how it started. I mean, we were talking about a bunch of stuff, but there was a problem recently.
But we'd already started driving and we hadn't taken the microphone out, so we didn't record any of it but uh i'm i'm a little fascinated with uh the mac scan and some of the properties of scans of that type and so i think we're going to talk a little bit more about it so the the thing that fascinated me was right uh should we tell the problem first well kind of you've already kind of ruined the solution a little bit uh but you know what we're not going to spoil it well we did spoil it, but so this is how it started. I mean, we were talking about a bunch of stuff, but there was a problem recently.|||但我们已经开始开车了，还没把麦克风拿出来，所以这些内容都没录下来。不过，呃，我……我对……max scan 以及这类 scan 的一些特性有点着迷，所以我想我们接下来会多聊聊这个。那么，让我着迷的是，对吧……呃，我们先说说那个问题吗？嗯，某种程度上你已经把答案剧透了一点，呃，不过你知道吗，我们不会剧透的。好吧，其实我们已经剧透了，但事情是这样的。我是说，我们聊了很多杂七杂八的东西，但最近有一个问题。
Who has seen it? I believe I talk about it in my KXCon talk, so if that's online and you've seen it, you will know the solution to this problem, but the problem I call the skyline problem, and it's pretty simple you're given a vector of integers that represent heights of buildings in a skyline and the question is if you're standing on the left hand side of these buildings what is the distinct or unique
Who has seen it? I believe I talk about it in my KXCon talk, so if that's online and you've seen it, you will know the solution to this problem, but the problem I call the skyline problem, and it's pretty simple you're given a vector of integers that represent heights of buildings in a skyline and the question is if you're standing on the left hand side of these buildings what is the distinct or unique|||谁看过？我相信我在 KXCon 的演讲中提到过它，所以如果那个视频在网上而且你看过，你就会知道这个问题的解法。但我把这个问题称为天际线问题，它非常简单：给你一个整数向量，代表天际线中建筑物的高度，问题是，如果你站在这些建筑物的左侧，你能看到的
number of buildings that you can see um and so for example example, a test case would be, say you have five integers, two, one, three, two, five. And the answer, given these five buildings, is that you can see three of them. You can see the first two, and then the second building that has a height of one you can't see because it's hidden behind the first building of two.
number of buildings that you can see um and so for example example, a test case would be, say you have five integers, two, one, three, two, five. And the answer, given these five buildings, is that you can see three of them. You can see the first two, and then the second building that has a height of one you can't see because it's hidden behind the first building of two.|||不同或独特的建筑物数量是多少？呃，所以例如，一个测试用例是，假设你有五个整数：2、1、3、2、5。根据这五栋建筑物，答案是你可以看到其中的三栋。你可以看到前两栋，然后第二栋高度为 1 的建筑物你看不到，因为它被第一栋高度为 2 的建筑物挡住了。
You can see the third building with a height of three. The fourth building with a height of two you also can't see because it's blocked behind the first building of two. You can see the third building with a height of three. The fourth building with a height of two, you also can't see because it's blocked by the middle building. And then you can see the last building that has a height of five. So basically any building that has a shorter height than any building to the left of it, you can't see. And that's the question. We'll throw it back to Bryce to say what he found. And we'll pause. We'll talk about how beautiful the view is oh it is gorgeous here uh we are we are driving through the uh the hills and mountains of austria and uh you know it's pretty flat in vienna but um and we were on the highway for a while but we we
You can see the third building with a height of three. The fourth building with a height of two you also can't see because it's hidden behind the first building of two. You can see the third building with a height of three. The fourth building with a height of two, you also can't see because it's blocked by the middle building. And then you can see the last building that has a height of five. So basically any building that has a shorter height than any building to the left of it, you can't see. And that's the question. We'll throw it back to Bryce to say what he found. And we'll pause. We'll talk about how beautiful the view is oh it is gorgeous here uh we are we are driving through the uh the hills and mountains of austria and uh you know it's pretty flat in vienna but um and we were on the highway for a while but we we|||你可以看到第三栋高度为 3 的建筑物。第四栋高度为 2 的建筑物你同样看不到，因为它被第一栋高度为 2 的建筑物挡在后面。你可以看到第三栋高度为 3 的建筑物。第四栋高度为 2 的建筑物，你也看不到，因为它被中间的建筑物挡住了。然后你可以看到最后一栋高度为 5 的建筑物。所以基本上，任何高度低于其左侧任何建筑物的建筑物，你都看不到。这就是这个问题。我们把话筒交回给布莱斯，听听他的发现。然后我们暂停一下。我们来聊聊这里的风景有多美。哦，这里太美了！呃，我们正开车穿过……奥地利的丘陵和山脉。呃，你知道的，维也纳比较平坦，但是……我们在高速公路上开了一会儿，不过我们……
now are off the highway we're in sort of like rural Austria, driving west. And then, well, now I think we just took the turn heading south, south to sort of the western part of Slovenia where the city of Bled is. And, yeah, it's absolutely gorgeous. It's, you know, what you think of when you think of Austria, the rolling hills, the sound of music-esque stuff, and there's all these beautiful old buildings that we keep seeing and churches and stuff like that. I just realized we're probably making history right now.
now are off the highway we're in sort of like rural Austria, driving west. And then, well, now I think we just took the turn heading south, south to sort of the western part of Slovenia where the city of Bled is. And, yeah, it's absolutely gorgeous. It's, you know, what you think of when you think of Austria, the rolling hills, the sound of music-esque stuff, and there's all these beautiful old buildings that we keep seeing and churches and stuff like that. I just realized we're probably making history right now.|||现在已经下了高速，来到类似于奥地利乡村的地方，向西行驶。然后，嗯，现在我想我们刚拐了个弯，开始向南行驶，向南前往斯洛文尼亚西部布莱德市所在的地区。而且，是的，这里绝对美极了。这就是你一想到奥地利就会浮现的景象——起伏的山丘、《音乐之声》般的风光，我们一路上不断看到各种美丽的古老建筑、教堂之类的。我刚意识到我们现在可能正在创造历史。
We might be the first ever podcast to be recorded during a road trip while one person's behind the wheel, one person's in the passenger seat, definitely it's got to be the first tech podcast that's ever done something like this. I will assure you, this is not the first road trip podcast. I bet there are lots of road trip podcasts. Are we technical for a technology podcast? We got to be the first. I, perhaps, perhaps I will, I will humor you. But you know this kind of kind of the area we're in right now kind of reminds me of the pacific northwest just because the really really tall
We might be the first ever podcast to be recorded during a road trip while one person's behind the wheel, one person's in the passenger seat, definitely it's got to be the first tech podcast that's ever done something like this. I will assure you, this is not the first road trip podcast. I bet there are lots of road trip podcasts. Are we technical for a technology podcast? We got to be the first. I, perhaps, perhaps I will, I will humor you. But you know this kind of kind of the area we're in right now kind of reminds me of the pacific northwest just because the really really tall|||我们可能是史上第一个在公路旅行中录制的播客，当时一个人在开车，一个人坐在副驾驶座上，这绝对是第一个做这种事的科技播客。我向你保证，这绝不是第一个公路旅行播客。我敢说有大量的公路旅行播客。就科技播客而言，我们算科技类的吗？我们肯定是第一个。我，也许，也许我会，我会顺着你的话说。但你知道我们现在所处这片区域，有点让我想起太平洋西北地区，就因为那些真的非常非常高的
trees um yeah it's absolutely gorgeous all right so people people have had a few minutes to think about we're whipping around these corners a little too fast. We've got to slow down here. We are definitely going to get some speeding tickets. No, I don't think so. Look, it's got a little happy face. No, it's got a sad face. There was a little, like, check your speed sign that's like, and it read our speed
trees um yeah it's absolutely gorgeous all right so people people have had a few minutes to think about we're whipping around these corners a little too fast. We've got to slow down here. We are definitely going to get some speeding tickets. No, I don't think so. Look, it's got a little happy face. No, it's got a sad face. There was a little, like, check your speed sign that's like, and it read our speed|||树木，呃，是的，绝对美极了。好了，大家已经有几分钟时间来思考了……我们过这些弯道有点太快了。我们得在这里减速。我们肯定会吃到超速罚单的。不，我不这么觉得。看，那里有个笑脸。不对，是个哭脸。那里有一个类似于“检查车速”的标志，它读取了我们的车速，
and it had a sad face. Yeah, but people have had a couple of minutes to think about the solution, how they would solve it. Alright, now you can had a couple of minutes to think about the solution, how they would solve it. All right, now you can say what you'd like to say, Bryce. Well, the solution, which my first thought was
and it had a sad face. Yeah, but people have had a couple of minutes to think about the solution, how they would solve it. Alright, now you can had a couple of minutes to think about the solution, how they would solve it. All right, now you can say what you'd like to say, Bryce. Well, the solution, which my first thought was|||然后上面显示了一个哭脸。是的，不过大家已经有几分钟时间来思考解决方案以及他们会如何解决它了。好了，现在你可以……已经有几分钟时间思考解决方案以及如何解决它了。好了，现在你可以说你想说的话了，布莱斯。嗯，这个解决方案，我最初的想法是
that this was some form of adjacent reduce, but Connor talked me out of that because I thought that maybe you just needed to have sort of two pieces of information, like the height of the thing and then how many buildings are in the information that you've reduced. But you actually need more than that. You need sort of like some compression of all of the information on all of the heights of the buildings. So that doesn't really work. But what the decision that Connor put forth was that you do a max scan,
that this was some form of adjacent reduce, but Connor talked me out of that because I thought that maybe you just needed to have sort of two pieces of information, like the height of the thing and then how many buildings are in the information that's reduced. But you actually need more than that. You need sort of like some compression of all of the information on all of the heights of the buildings. So that doesn't really work. But what the decision that Connor put forth was that you do a max scan,|||这某种程度上是某种相邻归约（adjacent reduce），但康纳说服我放弃了这个想法，因为我当时觉得，可能你只需要两种信息，比如物体的高度，以及被归约的信息中包含多少栋建筑。但实际上你需要的远不止这些。你需要对所有建筑高度的所有信息进行某种压缩。所以这种方法行不通。不过康纳提出的方案是，做一个 max scan（最大值扫描），
so a scan with, you know, stood max if we're in C++. And then you do a, what did you call it, the deduplicate. So, yeah, in the Q language, this is known as distinct, and I think some functional languages call it distinct as well. In Rust, it's known as deduplicate. We don't actually have this function in C++, at least in the standard algorithms. We have a similar version of this called std unique,
so a scan with, you know, stood max if we're in C++. And then you do a, what did you call it, the deduplicate. So, yeah, in the Q language, this is known as distinct, and I think some functional languages call it distinct as well. In Rust, it's known as deduplicate. We don't actually have this function in C++, at least in the standard algorithms. We have a similar version of this called std unique,|||也就是说，如果你在 C++ 中，就用 std::max 做一个 scan。然后你做一个……你叫它什么来着……deduplicate（去重）。所以，是的，在 Q 语言中，这被称为 distinct，我想一些函数式语言也叫它 distinct。在 Rust 中，它被称为 deduplicate。我们在 C++ 中其实没有这个函数，至少标准算法库里没有。我们有一个类似的版本叫 std::unique，
but unique, if you are familiar with, it removes adjacent elements that are equal, whereas deduplicate or distinct removes any uh repeated values regardless of where they show up so in q after you do your max scan you make a call to distinct which basically in our initial example of two one three two five that's going to turn that into two two three three five and then you want to basically remove the duplicate values. So you get rid of one of the twos, one of the threes, and you're left with 235.
but unique, if you are familiar with, it removes adjacent elements that are equal, whereas deduplicate or distinct removes any uh repeated values regardless of where they show up so in q after you do your max scan you make a call to distinct which basically in our initial example of two one three two five that's going to turn that into two two three three five and then you want to basically remove the duplicate values. So you get rid of one of the twos, one of the threes, and you're left with 235.|||但如果你熟悉 unique 的话，它移除的是相等的相邻元素，而 deduplicate 或 distinct 会移除任何呃重复的值，不管它们出现在哪里。所以在 Q 语言中，在你做了 max scan 之后，你调用 distinct，基本上在我们最初的例子“2、1、3、2、5”中，它会把它变成“2、2、3、3、5”，然后你基本上想要移除重复的值。所以你去掉一个 2，去掉一个 3，剩下的就是 2、3、5。
And then you just do a count of that, yeah. Yeah, in C++ that's a std size, and Rust it would be, I believe, count or len. But yeah, it's either called count, length, size, something like that in your various programming languages. But the realization that Connor had, so that deduplicate operation, it does not assume that the input sequence is sorted. Correct. And so that means that it's a little bit more expensive.
And then you just do a count of that, yeah. Yeah, in C++ that's a std size, and Rust it would be, I believe, count or len. But yeah, it's either called count, length, size, something like that in your various programming languages. But the realization that Connor had, so that deduplicate operation, it does not assume that the input sequence is sorted. Correct. And so that means that it's a little bit more expensive.|||然后你只需对它进行计数，对吧。对，在 C++ 中这就是 std::size，在 Rust 中我想应该是 count 或 len。但没错，在各种编程语言中它要么叫 count、length、size 或者是类似的名字。但康纳意识到的是，那个 deduplicate 操作并不假设输入序列是有序的。没错。所以这就意味着它的开销要稍大一些。
So how do you implement that? So, yeah, I was doing this in a sort of toy thing I was working on, and my implementation of distinct was just to allocate some small hash set, memory for a small hash set, and then you just keep track of all the values you've seen. So that's the naive implementation of how you remove duplicates from a list. But after thinking about, you know about the solution to this problem, I realized that one of the properties of a max scan is that it's sorted.
So how do you implement that? So, yeah, I was doing this in a sort of toy thing I was working on, and my implementation of distinct was just to allocate some small hash set, memory for a small hash set, and then you just keep track of all the values you've seen. So that's the naive implementation of how you remove duplicates from a list. But after thinking about, you know about the solution to this problem, I realized that one of the properties of a max scan is that it's sorted.|||那么你该如何实现它呢？所以，是的，我当时正在做一个小玩具项目，我实现 distinct 的方法就是分配一些小型哈希集合（hash set），为小型哈希集合分配内存，然后你只需记录所有你见过的值。所以这就是从列表中去除重复项的朴素实现。但在思考了……你知道的，关于这个问题的解法之后，我意识到 max scan 的属性之一就是它是排序的。
And if you know you have a sorted sequence, you don't actually need to make a call to an algorithm that is doing deduplication. You actually can make use of the more efficient algorithm that exists in C++, which is kind of the overarching point algorithm that exists in C++ that's unique, which is kind of the overarching point of this conversation that we had earlier, is that there are certain operations such as sort or max scan that leave you with a sorted sequence, which then potentially you can dispatch to a more efficient algorithm. And in this example, it's the difference between making a call to something like distinct versus making something to that is called uh like unique in c++ yeah
And if you know you have a sorted sequence, you don't actually need to make a call to an algorithm that is doing deduplication. You actually can make use of the more efficient algorithm that exists in C++, which is kind of the overarching point algorithm that exists in C++ that's unique, which is kind of the overarching point of this conversation that we had earlier, is that there are certain operations such as sort or max scan that leave you with a sorted sequence, which then potentially you can dispatch to a more efficient algorithm. And in this example, it's the difference between making a call to something like distinct versus making something to that is called uh like unique in c++ yeah|||如果你知道你有一个有序序列，你其实就不需要调用执行去重的算法了。你实际上可以利用 C++ 中存在的更高效的算法，也就是 C++ 中那类总括性的算法——unique。这也是我们刚才那场对话的核心观点：存在某些操作（例如 sort 或 max scan），它们会产生一个有序序列，然后你可能会将它分发（dispatch）给更高效的算法。在这个例子中，这就好比调用像 distinct 这样的东西，与调用诸如 C++ 中被称为……呃，unique 这样的东西之间的区别。是的。
yeah and so i i uh i think that this category of scans that uh leave you with a monotonically increasing sequence for lack of a better term or monotonically decreasing if it's like a min scan, but that leave you with a sequence that is sorted, I think that's very interesting. And I can't recall a specific problem in the past where we've used one of these scans, but I suspect we probably have. But I want to learn more about this type of scan and whether there's other interesting use cases or properties of this. Yeah, can you think of another problem that we've talked about where we've solved it with a max scan or where we've solved it with something with a scan that leaves it in a monotonically increasing state? So off the top of my head, we mentioned this earlier.
yeah and so i i uh i think that this category of scans that uh leave you with a monotonically increasing sequence for lack of a better term or monotonically decreasing if it's like a min scan, but that leave you with a sequence that is sorted, I think that's very interesting. And I can't recall a specific problem in the past where we've used one of these scans, but I suspect we probably have. But I want to learn more about this type of scan and whether there's other interesting use cases or properties of this. Yeah, can you think of another problem that we've talked about where we've solved it with a max scan or where we've solved it with something with a scan that leaves it in a monotonically increasing state? So off the top of my head, we mentioned this earlier.|||对，所以我……呃，我觉得这类 scan（找不到更好的词来形容了）会产生一个单调递增的序列（如果是个 min scan 就是单调递减），但总之它们会留下一个有序序列，我觉得这非常有趣。而且我想不起来过去有什么具体问题用到过这种 scan，但我猜我们大概率用过。不过我想更多地了解这种类型的 scan，以及它是否还有其他有趣的用例或属性。是的，你能想到我们讨论过的另一个问题吗？我们用 max scan 解决了它，或者用某种带有 scan 且让它保持单调递增状态的操作解决了它？我想了一下，我们刚才提到过这个。
This one makes use of two max scans, but it's not followed by a reduction or like a call to unique or something like that. So there's not a huge thing to be taken advantage of there. But for folks that have seen my C++ Now 2019 talk, I covered a problem that I call rainwater. And both Skyline and rainwater are a part of my top 10 GitHub repository. Man, it is so pretty where we are right now. It is absolutely gorgeous.
This one makes use of two max scans, but it's not followed by a reduction or like a call to unique or something like that. So there's not a huge thing to be taken advantage of there. But for folks that have seen my C++ Now 2019 talk, I covered a problem that I call rainwater. And both Skyline and rainwater are a part of my top 10 GitHub repository. Man, it is so pretty where we are right now. It is absolutely gorgeous.|||这个用到了两个 max scan，但它后面没有跟 reduction（归约）或者像调用 unique 之类的操作。所以那里没有什么大不了的东西可以利用。但对于看过我 2019 年 C++ Now 演讲的人来说，我讲过一个我称之为 rainwater（雨水）的问题。Skyline（天际线）和 rainwater（雨水）都是我 GitHub 排名前 10 的仓库的一部分。天哪，我们现在所在的这个地方太漂亮了。简直美极了。
I was just thinking that. We just passed by this little, we're driving next to this little stream in this like valley in between these beautiful mountains. We gotta take a photo so that we can post this on the episode. I was just about to do that. This is slightly less iconic than it was a moment ago. But this is looking like it's going to return to being iconic and idyllic,
I was just thinking that. We just passed by this little, we're driving next to this little stream in this like valley in between these beautiful mountains. We gotta take a photo so that we can post this on the episode. I was just about to do that. This is slightly less iconic than it was a moment ago. But this is looking like it's going to return to being iconic and idyllic,|||我刚才也这么想。我们刚刚路过这个小……我们正沿着群山环抱的山谷中的这条小溪开车。我们得拍张照片，好发到这一期的节目动态里。我正准备这么做呢。这里的标志性景观比刚才稍微少了一点。但看起来它又要恢复那种标志性和田园般的感觉了，
maybe is the word I'm looking for. But yeah, C++ Now, 2019, Rainwater, Skyline, both are on my top 10 GitHub repo. And that problem, it's very similar to the Skyline problem. You're given a skyline once again, except in this problem statement, they call it like a mountainous range. And you have to calculate
maybe is the word I'm looking for. But yeah, C++ Now, 2019, Rainwater, Skyline, both are on my top 10 GitHub repo. And that problem, it's very similar to the Skyline problem. You're given a skyline once again, except in this problem statement, they call it like a mountainous range. And you have to calculate|||也许这就是我想找的词。不过是的，C++ Now 2019，Rainwater、Skyline，都在我的 GitHub Top 10 仓库里。那个问题和 Skyline 问题非常相似。再次给你一个天际线，只不过在这个问题陈述中，他们称之为山脉（mountainous range）。你必须计算
if it were to rain on this mountainous range, you know, how much water would be trapped in these kind of pockets formed between these, you know, integer heights of varying heights. And here you do a max scan from the left, a max scan from the right, and then you do what's now called a zip transform in C++, where you take the difference between those two.
if it were to rain on this mountainous range, you know, how much water would be trapped in these kind of pockets formed between these, you know, integer heights of varying heights. And here you do a max scan from the left, a max scan from the right, and then you do what's now called a zip transform in C++, where you take the difference between those two.|||如果在这片山脉上下雨，你知道的，会有多少水被困在这些不同高度的整数高度之间形成的口袋里。在这里，你从左边做一个 max scan，从右边做一个 max scan，然后做现在在 C++ 中称为 zip transform（压缩变换）的操作，即求这两者之间的差值。
So that's an example of when you use a max scan. Another example is, we were talking about this, when you're doing string trimming, if you want to get rid of like the leading zeros or sorry leading spaces at the beginning or end of a string that technically I'm going to stop talking so I don't there's a guy on a motorcycle and Connor's attempting to not hit the guy not hit the guy we've been successful been successful so far stay tuned folks uh you know you'll be you'll be hearing this episode I believe what was it yesterday the 16 You know, you'll be hearing this episode, I believe. What was it yesterday? The 16th.
So that's an example of when you use a max scan. Another example is, we were talking about this, when you're doing string trimming, if you want to get rid of like the leading zeros or sorry leading spaces at the beginning or end of a string that technically I'm going to stop talking so I don't there's a guy on a motorcycle and Connor's attempting to not hit the guy not hit the guy we've been successful been successful so far stay tuned folks uh you know you'll be you'll be hearing this episode I believe what was it yesterday the 16|||所以这就是使用 max scan 的一个例子。另一个例子是，我们之前讨论过的，当你在做字符串修剪（string trimming）时，如果你想去掉字符串开头或结尾的前导零，哦不，前导空格，严格来说……我要停止说话了，免得……有个骑摩托车的家伙，康纳正试图不撞到那家伙，不撞到那家伙，我们成功了，目前为止很成功，大家敬请期待，呃，你知道的，你们会听到这一期节目，我相信，昨天是几号？16号。
So you're hearing this either on, like, June 23rd or 24th, depending on how recently or quickly you listen to the episode. And also whether we survive. Yeah, that's true. I guess, though, if we've hit someone, we've hit them by now. By the time you're listening to it, you might not know about it. But we've crashed or hit someone, we've hit them by now. By the time you're listening to it, you might not know about it, but we've crashed or hit someone. Because at this point, you're already back.
You know, you'll be hearing this episode, I believe. What was it yesterday? The 16th. So you're hearing this either on, like, June 23rd or 24th, depending on how recently or quickly you listen to the episode. And also whether we survive. Yeah, that's true. I guess, though, if we've hit someone, we've hit them by now. By the time you're listening to it, you might not know about it. But we've crashed or hit someone, we've hit them by now. By the time you're listening to it, you might not know about it, but we've crashed or hit someone. Because at this point, you're already back.|||你知道的，你们听到这期节目时，我相信……昨天是几号？16号。所以你们听到这期节目的时候，大概是在 6 月 23 日或 24 日，这取决于你们听得有多近、多快。还有就是我们是否还活着。对，也是。不过我想，如果我们撞了人，到现在已经撞了。等你们听到的时候，你们可能还不知道。但如果我们车祸了或者撞了人，现在就已经撞了。等你们听到的时候，你们可能还不知道，但我们已经车祸或撞人了。因为到了那个时候，你已经回去了。
Are you stateside by Friday? Yeah, I'll be home by Thursday. You won't be there. You're just staying here until the next conference. Yeah, I'll be Ooh, look at that Lamborghini. Lamborghini in the hills of... Holy shit. A lot of fancy cars just passed by us.
Are you stateside by Friday? Yeah, I'll be home by Thursday. You won't be there. You're just staying here until the next conference. Yeah, I'll be Ooh, look at that Lamborghini. Lamborghini in the hills of... Holy shit. A lot of fancy cars just passed by us.|||你周五前能回美国吗？对，我周四就能到家。你不会在那儿。你只是留在这里直到下个会议。对，我会……噢，看那辆兰博基尼！奥地利群山中的兰博基尼……卧槽。刚才有好多豪车从我们旁边开过去。
Man, we got to go find out who they were. Yeah. They're probably going to the Sound of Music Museum. Oh, it's definitely got to be a thing. But yes, removing the leading zeros off of strings and stuff like that that basically is a min scan after you transform your string into a sequence or not necessarily a sequence you basically create a sequence of trues and falses aka ones and zeros where the ones correspond to if it's a space or not and then you can do a what's typically known as a logical and scan but uh as we were
Man, we got to go find out who they were. Yeah. They're probably going to the Sound of Music Museum. Oh, it's definitely got to be a thing. But yes, removing the leading zeros off of strings and stuff like that that basically is a min scan after you transform your string into a sequence or not necessarily a sequence you basically create a sequence of trues and falses aka ones and zeros where the ones correspond to if it's a space or not and then you can do a what's typically known as a logical and scan but uh as we were|||天哪，我们得去查查他们是谁。对。他们可能是去《音乐之声》博物馆吧。哦，那绝对是个必去景点。不过话说回来，去除字符串的前导零之类的事情，基本上就是把字符串转换成序列（或者不一定是序列，你基本上是创建一个由布尔值 true 和 false 即 1 和 0 组成的序列，其中 1 对应是否为空格），在你做了这些之后，再进行一个 min scan。然后你可以做一个通常被称为逻辑与扫描（logical and scan）的操作，但呃，正如我们刚才
talking about earlier in array languages um some of them basically extend the logical and and or to min and max because logical and and or are just the min and max in the space of zeros and ones in array languages because booleans are just zeros and ones, which also is, I think, an incredibly interesting property of array languages because they treat Booleans as just a subset of the sort of values that integers can take, a.k.a. zeros and ones. I don't know. Those are a few examples. Yeah, I feel like we often on this podcast,
talking about earlier in array languages some of them basically extend the logical and and or to min and max because logical and and or are just the min and max in the space of zeros and ones in array languages because booleans are just zeros and ones, which also is, I think, an incredibly interesting property of array languages because they treat Booleans as just a subset of the sort of values that integers can take, a.k.a. zeros and ones. I don't know. Those are a few examples. Yeah, I feel like we often on this podcast,|||在数组语言（array languages）中讨论的那样，其中一些语言基本上将逻辑与（logical and）和逻辑或（logical or）扩展到了 min 和 max，因为在数组语言中，逻辑与和逻辑或在 0 和 1 的空间里恰好就是 min 和 max，因为布尔值本质上就是 0 和 1。这也是我认为数组语言一个极其有趣的特性，因为它们将布尔值视为整数可以取的值的一种子集，也就是 0 和 1。我不知道。这些就是几个例子。对，我觉得我们在这个播客里经常……
we talk about, when we talk about algorithms, we talk about scans and reductions and transforms and various different adjacent algorithms and zips and things of that nature, but we do not frequently talk about sorted sequences and operations on sorted sequences. I mean, I'm sure we've talked about it a little bit, but have you noticed that as well?
we talk about, when we talk about algorithms, we talk about scans and reductions and transforms and various different adjacent algorithms and zips and things of that nature, but we do not frequently talk about sorted sequences and operations on sorted sequences. I mean, I'm sure we've talked about it a little bit, but have you noticed that as well?|||当我们谈论算法时，我们会谈论 scans、reductions、transforms、各种不同的相邻算法以及 zips 和诸如此类的东西，但我们并不经常谈论有序序列以及对有序序列的操作。我是说，我确信我们稍微讨论过一点，但你也注意到了这一点吗？
I mean, what do you mean when you say we don't talk about operations on sorted sequences? I think they do not come up. I think sorted sequences do not come up as frequently in the algorithms that we talk about and the problems that we talk about. Yeah, well, so I think especially in GPU parallel land, you want to try and avoid sorts as often as possible
I mean, what do you mean when you say we don't talk about operations on sorted sequences? I think they do not come up. I think sorted sequences do not come up as frequently in the algorithms that we talk about and the problems that we talk about. Yeah, well, so I think especially in GPU parallel land, you want to try and avoid sorts as often as possible|||我是说，当你 M 说我们不谈论对有序序列的操作时，你是什么意思？我觉得它们不常出现。我觉得在我们讨论的算法和问题中，有序序列没有那么频繁地出现。是的，嗯，所以我认为特别是在 GPU 并行领域，你会希望尽可能经常地避免排序（sort），
because compared to reduces and scans and transforms, they are not the bread and butter that... Obviously, we can accelerate sorts we do but uh compared to like if you can express your problem in terms of reduction scans and transforms that's the preferable way to spell your solution and so like in that regard yeah we don't talk about sorts a ton but i think what's really interesting is that the observation that there are different operations that can leave you with a sorted sequence aka a max scan a max scan is an operation that when you perform on a sequence by definition you will have or sorry you perform on any sequence by definition you will end up with a sorted sequence
because compared to reduces and scans and transforms, they are not the bread and butter that... Obviously, we can accelerate sorts we do but uh compared to like if you can express your problem in terms of reduction scans and transforms that's the preferable way to spell your solution and so like in that regard yeah we don't talk about sorts a ton but i think what's really interesting is that the observation that there are different operations that can leave you with a sorted sequence aka a max scan a max scan is an operation that when you perform on a sequence by definition you will have or sorry you perform on any sequence by definition you will end up with a sorted sequence|||因为与 reduces、scans 和 transforms 相比，它们并不是那种……显而易见，我们可以加速排序，我们确实也这么做，但呃，相比之下，如果你能用 reduction、scan 和 transform 来表达你的问题，那才是表述你解决方案的首选方式。所以在这一点上，是的，我们不怎么经常谈论排序，但我认为真正有趣的是这样一个观察：存在不同的操作可以产生一个有序序列，也就是 max scan。max scan 这种操作，当你对一个序列执行时，根据定义你将拥有——或者抱歉，你对任何序列执行时，根据定义你最终都会得到一个有序序列。
and if it's a max scan that brings you to a sorted sequence well now it's now you're talking about like we're still in like the uh bread and butter area of what uh gpus are good at um and i think and that's what's really interesting one of the things that led me to have this eureka moment or sort of realization was that in the Q language, when you actually make a call to the sort function, which they call ASC, or the reverse sort is DECS, so like ask and desk, short for ascending and descending, it will, in the REPL, prefix your integer sequence with like an S backtick, which indicates that it's a sorted sequence i'm not sure how the implementation of q works but i wouldn't be surprised if then you know q is able to take advantage of the knowledge that that sequence or maybe it's just a visual thing
and if it's a max scan that brings you to a sorted sequence well now it's now you're talking about like we're still in like the uh bread and butter area of what uh gpus are good at um and i think and that's what's really interesting one of the things that led me to have this eureka moment or sort of realization was that in the Q language, when you actually make a call to the sort function, which they call ASC, or the reverse sort is DECS, so like ask and desk, short for ascending and descending, it will, in the REPL, prefix your integer sequence with like an S backtick, which indicates that it's a sorted sequence i'm not sure how the implementation of q works but i wouldn't be surprised if then you know q is able to take advantage of the knowledge that that sequence or maybe it's just a visual thing|||如果是一个能带给你有序序列的 max scan，那么现在……现在你所讨论的，就好像我们依然处于呃 GPU 擅长的核心领域。呃，我觉得这正是最有趣的地方。促成我有这种“尤里卡”时刻或某种领悟的原因之一是，在 Q 语言中，当你实际调用排序函数（他们称之为 ASC，反向排序则是 DECS，就像 ask 和 desk 一样，是 ascending 和 descending 的缩写）时，它会在 REPL 中你的整数序列前面加上一个类似 `S`` 的前缀，这表明它是一个有序序列。我不太清楚 Q 的底层实现是如何运作的，但我不会感到惊讶，如果 Q 能够利用这种认知，即知道该序列是……或者也许这只是一个视觉效果，
maybe there are no like different dispatches to different algorithm implementations but um if you do a max scan in uh the q repl it doesn't prefix it with an s back tick so like even though it is a sorted sequence, it's not telling you the same information. It only tells you that after you make a call to ASC and DE ask and desk, their two sorting functions, which, like I said, I don't actually know anything about the implementation of queue because it's a proprietary language, but I think it's a missed opportunity if there are some, like,
maybe there are no like different dispatches to different algorithm implementations but um if you do a max scan in uh the q repl it doesn't prefix it with an s back tick so like even though it is a sorted sequence, it's not telling you the same information. It only tells you that after you make a call to ASC and DE ask and desk, their two sorting functions, which, like /I said, I don't actually know anything about the implementation of queue because it's a proprietary language, but I think it's a missed opportunity if there are some, like,|||也许并不存在针对不同算法实现的 不同分发逻辑，但是呃，如果你在 Q 的 REPL 中做一个 max scan，它不会给它加上 `S`` 前缀，所以尽管它是一个有序序列，它并没有告诉你相同的信息。它只告诉你，在你调用 ASC 和 DE（ask 和 desk，它们的两个排序函数）之后才有。就像我说的，我其实对 Q 的实现一无所知，因为它是闭源的专有语言，但我认为如果存在某些……
dispatching to different algorithm implementations based on this little piece of Boolean information. All you would have to do is add this little same Boolean information to a sequence after MaxScan or MinScan. Off the top of my head, are there any other operations that result in sorted sequences that aren't sort or max or min scan? I suspect there have to be. Like you could say like an and scan, a logical and scan, and a logical or scan,
dispatching to different algorithm implementations based on this little piece of Boolean information. All you would have to do is add this little same Boolean information to a sequence after MaxScan or MinScan. Off the top of my head, are there any other operations that result in sorted sequences that aren't sort or max or min scan? I suspect there have to be. Like you could say like an and scan, a logical and scan, and a logical or scan,|||根据这一小段布尔信息分发到不同的算法实现中，却没有这样做，那就错失了一个良机。你所需要做的，就是在 MaxScan 或 MinScan 之后的序列上添加这个相同的布尔信息。我脑海里临时想一下，除了 sort、max scan 或 min scan 之外，还有没有其他操作也能产生有序序列？我猜肯定有的。比如你可以说像 and scan、logical and scan 和 logical or scan，
but those are just extensions of min scans and max scans. But still, like some people might think of those as separate things, like technically, I guess any of, none of, and all of those are reductions. But if we had... Okay, but so I'll pause it. No, it's not going to be any comparator.
but those are just extensions of min scans and max scans. But still, like some people might think of those as separate things, like technically, I guess any of, none of, and all of those are reductions. But if we had... Okay, but so I'll pause it. No, it's not going to be any comparator.|||但这些只是 min scan 和 max scan 的扩展。不过话又说回来，有些人可能会把这些当作独立的东西，比如严格来说，我猜 any of、none of 和 all of 这些全都是 reductions。但如果我们有……好吧，那我先暂停一下。不，不会是什么任意比较器（comparator）。
There must be some other family, right? Because, I mean, maybe they all boil down to max scans or min scans. If you think about, like, sort, like, there's other sorting comparators other than just less than and greater than. So maybe that would help. Maybe if we think about other common sort comparators, that may lead us to other scans that have this property. Well, no, when you say less than, greater than, those are equality operators,
There must be some other family, right? Because, I mean, maybe they all boil down to max scans or min scans. If you think about, like, sort, like, there's other sorting comparators other than just less than and greater than. So maybe that would help. Maybe if we think about other common sort comparators, that may lead us to other scans that have this property. Well, no, when you say less than, greater than, those are equality operators,|||肯定还有其他家族，对吧？因为，我是说，也许它们最终都可以归结为 max scan 或 min scan。如果你想想，比如 sort，除了小于和大于之外，还有其他的排序比较器。所以也许这会有所帮助。也许如果我们考虑其他常见的排序比较器，可能会引导我们找到具有这种属性的其他 scan。不对，当你说是小于、大于时，那些是相等运算符（equality operators），——
meaning that they always return trues and falses. Right, right, right. But I'm saying, like, that that they always return trues and falses. Right, right, right. But I'm saying, I'm saying like, like that's, um, you know, if you look at like, what is,
meaning that they always return trues and falses. Right, right, right. But I'm saying, like, that that they always return trues and falses. Right, right, right. But I'm saying, I'm saying like, like that's, um, you know, if you look at like, what is,|||意思是它们总是返回 true 和 false。对，对，对。但我的意思是，它们总是返回 true 和 false。对，对，对。但我的意思是，我的意思是……那是个……你知道的，如果你看看……什么是……
what is Stidman and Stidmax do? Like, what's the comparison that they do? Uh, I mean, inside the operation, yes, there's a less than.
what is Stidman and Stidmax do? Like, what's the comparison that they do? Uh, I mean, inside the operation, yes, there's a less than.|||std::min 和 std::max 做的是什么？比如，它们做的是什么比较？呃，我的意思是，在操作内部，是的，有一个小于比较。
Right, right. And so if you think like, if we took like any arbitrary, like, uh, you know, comparator and so if you think like if we took like any arbitrary like uh you know comparator and you you uh like that you'd use for stood sort and you take that arbitrary comparator and you turn it into a you know if true then a then b then and then you do a scan with that
Right, right. And so if you think like, if we took like any arbitrary, like, uh, you know, comparator and so if you think like if we took like any arbitrary like uh you know comparator and you you uh like that you'd use for stood sort and you take that arbitrary comparator and you turn it into a you know if true then a then b then and then you do a scan with that|||对，对。所以如果你想，如果我们取任何任意的……你知道的……比较器，所以如果你想，如果我们取任何任意的……你知道的……比较器，就像你会用于 std::sort 的那样，然后你把那个任意比较器变成一个……你知道的……如果为真则返回 a，否则返回 b，然后用那个操作做一个 scan，
operation so you get that same property yeah off the top of my head, I can't think of any. There's some... Let me look at the specification of sort. Because what's the property that your comparator has to guarantee? We have internet again, which is helpful for most importantly
operation so you get that same property yeah off the top of my head, I can't think of any. There's some... Let me look at the specification of sort. Because what's the property that your comparator has to guarantee? We have internet again, which is helpful for most importantly|||你就会得到相同的属性。是的，我一时想不出任何其他的。有一些……让我看一下 sort 的规范。因为你的比较器必须保证什么属性？我们又有网络了，这很有帮助，最重要的是
answering this question and also making sure that we arrive in Slovenia. And also apparently we have to buy this sticker that we put on the car so they don't charge us a bunch of money. Well, listener, if you know of any operations other than sort and min scans and
answering this question and also making sure that we arrive in Slovenia. And also apparently we have to buy this sticker that we put on the car so they don't charge us a bunch of money. Well, listener, if you know of any operations other than sort and min scans and|||它可以回答这个问题，还能确保我们能到达斯洛文尼亚。而且显然我们还得买这个贴纸贴在车上，这样他们就不会向我们收取一大笔钱了。听众朋友们，如果你知道除了 sort、min scan 和
max scans, I'd be curious to know. I think actually also, too, a few episodes ago now, we were having a discussion and we were trying to talk about algorithms that are similar to filter. I think this was back when we were talking about, uh, parallelizing filter. Um, and I was trying to think of other algorithms that are similar to transformations, but they are, are not shape preserving. So like a filter is not a shape-preserving operation.
max scans, I'd be curious to know. I think actually also, too, a few episodes ago now, we were having a discussion and we were trying to talk about algorithms that are similar to filter. I think this was back when we were talking about, uh, parallelizing filter. Um, and I was trying to think of other algorithms that are similar to transformations, but they are, are not shape preserving. So like a filter is not a shape-preserving operation.|||max scan之外的任何其他操作，我很想知道。其实还有，就在几期节目之前，我们讨论过，试图谈论类似于 filter（过滤）的算法。我想那是在我们讨论呃并行化 filter 的时候。呃，我当时在试图想出其他类似于 transformation（变换）但它们不保持形状（shape-preserving）的算法。所以像 filter 就不是一个保持形状的操作。
And I think off the top of my head, I couldn't think of any, but then I thought of a bunch later. So we've been talking about unique and distinct, and both of those are non-shape-preserving filter-like operations. There was a couple others, too. But anyways, point being is no one, I don't think anyone tweeted at us other algorithms that fit into that category,
And I think off the top of my head, I couldn't think of any, but then I thought of a bunch later. So we've been talking about unique and distinct, and both of those are non-shape-preserving filter-like operations. There was a couple others, too. But anyways, point being is no one, I don't think anyone tweeted at us other algorithms that fit into that category,|||我想我当时一时想不起来，但后来我想出了一堆。所以我们一直在讨论 unique 和 distinct，这两者都是不保持形状的类 filter 操作。还有另外几个。但不管怎样，重点是没人——我觉得没人发推给我们推荐其他符合该类别的算法，
but there are a bunch. Yeah, filter. Oh yeah, and then take and drop. Those are not shape-preserving either. They're rank-preserving, but not shape-preserving. So yeah, take, drop, take while, drop while, filter, unique, distinct. There's a bunch of them. preserving but not shape preserving um so yeah take drop take while drop while filter unique distinct there's a bunch of them so back to bryce so um i mean i do i do think that there's actually
but there are a bunch. Yeah, filter. Oh yeah, and then take and drop. Those are not shape-preserving either. They're rank-preserving, but not shape-preserving. So yeah, take, drop, take while, drop while, filter, unique, distinct. There's a bunch of them. preserving but not shape preserving um so yeah take drop take while drop while filter unique distinct there's a bunch of them so back to bryce so um i mean i do i do think that there's actually|||但实际上有一大堆。对，filter。哦对，还有 take 和 drop。这些也都不保持形状。它们保持秩（rank-preserving），但不保持形状。所以是的，take、drop、take while、drop while、filter、unique、distinct。有好多这样的算法。不保持形状，但……所以是的，take、drop、take while、drop while、filter、unique、distinct，有好多这样的算法。所以回到布莱斯，所以……呃，我是说，我确实觉得实际上有……
like a lot of these like if you do a if you do a wait are we talking about what i just said or are we going back to the max no we're going back to the max scan thing. Sorry. I was... I didn't even hear what you said. If you do just like a scan with like Operator Plus on positive integers, you'll get a sequence that's sort of... This is true. That's actually a classic competitive programming trick is when you need to figure out... Ooh.
like a lot of these like if you do a if you do a wait are we talking about what i just said or are we going back to the max no we're going back to the max scan thing. Sorry. I was... I didn't even hear what you said. If you do just like a scan with like Operator Plus on positive integers, you'll get a sequence that's sort of... This is true. That's actually a classic competitive programming trick is when you need to figure out... Ooh.|||其中很多……如果你做……如果你做……等等，我们是在谈论我刚才说的话，还是要回到 max 那里？不，我们回到 max scan 的事情上。抱歉。我当时……我甚至都没听清你说了什么。如果你只是用类似 Operator Plus 对正整数做一个 scan，你会得到一个序列，它某种程度上……这倒不假。这其实是一个经典的竞赛编程技巧，当你需要计算……噢。
Ooh, we took the wrong turn, folks. Did we? Did we take the wrong turn? I think we're good. That's not yelling at us. We're good. It's unclear. Did it say rerouting?
Ooh, we took the wrong turn, folks. Did we? Did we take the wrong turn? I think we're good. That's not yelling at us. We're good. It's unclear. Did it say rerouting?|||噢，各位，我们走错路了。是吗？我们走错路了吗？我觉得我们没走错。它没对我们大喊大叫。我们好着呢。还不清楚。它说重新规划路线了吗？
You mean are we connected to the internet? Uh, I am. I think it would be, it would be rerouting if it was, if we had messed up. We're good. We're good. Listen, folks, we're still good. No problemo here. Um, you are definitely correct. And there's a competitive programming trick that if you need to figure out, like, what's the maximum number of things that, like, you can chew up or you can consume,
You mean are we connected to the internet? Uh, I am. I think it would be, it would be rerouting if it was, if we had messed up. We're good. We're good. Listen, folks, we're still good. No problemo here. Um, you are definitely correct. And there's a competitive programming trick that if you need to figure out, like, what's the maximum number of things that, like, you can chew up or you can consume,|||你是说我们连接到互联网了吗？呃，我连着呢。我想如果是的话，如果我们搞砸了，它应该会重新规划路线。我们很好。我们很好。听着，各位，我们依然很好。这里没问题。呃，你绝对说得对。还有一个竞赛编程技巧，如果你需要计算出，比如，你可以嚼碎或消耗的最大物品数量是几，
one of the fastest ways to do this is to do a plus scan and then a binary search with some value on that, basically, the result of your plus scan. So, like, a plus scan on positive values with a binary search is like a classic solution to certain competitive programming problems. Wait, what do you mean by to chew up? So like what, I remember specifically there was this problem from like years ago, why I know the rough details of this is hard for me to fathom. But it's something like you are, you have like, you know, an army of people shooting bows and arrows. I mean, like the context of this problem doesn't really matter.
one of the fastest ways to do this is to do a plus scan and then a binary search with some value on that, basically, the result of your plus scan. So, like, a plus scan on positive values with a binary search is like a classic solution to certain competitive programming problems. Wait, what do you mean by to chew up? So like what, I remember specifically there was this problem from like years ago, why I know the rough details of this is hard for me to fathom. But it's something like you are, you have like, you know, an army of people shooting bows and arrows. I mean, like the context of this problem doesn't really matter.|||最快的方法之一就是做一个加法扫描（plus scan），然后用某个值对它进行二分查找，基本上就是对你的加法扫描的结果进行二分查找。所以，对正数值进行加法扫描再加上二分查找，可以说是解决某些竞赛编程问题的经典方案。等等，你说的“嚼碎”是什么意思？所以就像什么呢，我清楚地记得多年前有这样一个问题，为什么我会知道这题的大致细节，我自己都难以理解。但大概就是说你，你有一支……你知道的，射箭的军队。我是说，这个问题的背景其实不重要。
And then you are going to have these like waves of enemies coming in and they come in in these waves. And there's some like criteria where you're able to defeat each wave. And the question is like, how many waves can you survive? And the solution to this problem is by doing a plus scan and so you know that like each one of your battalions matches up against however many of them but like to do that naively and you end up with like a quadratic solution but if you just do a plus scan in advance on your whole sequence of enemies that you're going to be facing, you can just do like multiple binary searches. So instead of having a quadratic solution, you end up with like an
And then you are going to have these like waves of enemies coming in and they come in in these waves. There's some like criteria where you're able to defeat each wave. And the question is like, how many waves can you survive? And the solution to this problem is by doing a plus scan and so you know that like each one of your battalions matches up against however many of them but like to do that naively and you end up with like a quadratic solution but if you just do a plus scan in advance on your whole sequence of enemies that you're going to be facing, you can just do like multiple binary searches. So instead of having a quadratic solution, you end up with like an|||然后你会有成波的敌人涌进来，他们是一波一波地来的。有一些标准可以用来判定你是否能击败每一波敌人。问题是，你能挺过多少波敌人？解决这个问题的方法就是做一个加法扫描，这样你就知道你的每个营可以对抗多少敌人的进攻。但如果用朴素的方法去做，你最终会得到一个二次方时间复杂度的解法（quadratic solution），但如果你提前对你将要面对的整个敌人序列做一次加法扫描，你就可以进行多次二分查找。所以，你不用得到一个二次方复杂度的解法，而是会得到一个类似于……
n log n solution. Or no, yeah, it's a it's like a k log n solution, because log n on the size of the enemies that you're facing, and then K is like the number of times you're able to beat the waves or something like that. That was super hand wavy. I can find, I will go back and find, because I know actually I made a, the reason I remember the detail is now, this is coming back to me,
n log n solution. Or no, yeah, it's a it's like a k log n solution, because log n on the size of the enemies that you're facing, and then K is like the number of times you're able to beat the waves or something like that. That was super hand wavy. I can find, I will go back and find, because I know actually I made a, the reason I remember the detail is now, this is coming back to me,|||n log n 复杂度的解法。或者说，对，这是一个类似于 k log n 的解法，因为 log n 是针对你所面对的敌人规模而言的，而 K 是你能击败这些波次的次数之类的。这解释得太模糊了。我可以找到，我会回去找找，因为我知道我其实做过……我之所以还记得这个细节是因为，现在我想起来了，
I made a YouTube video back in the early days of my YouTube channel when it used to all be about competitive programming about this problem and I remember creating a little graphic of these little stickman figures with bows and arrows and I think I put Thor you know animation
I made a YouTube video back in the early days of my YouTube channel when it used to all be about competitive programming about this problem and I remember creating a little graphic of these little stickman figures with bows and arrows and I think I put Thor you know animation|||我在 YouTube 频道刚创办的早期做过一个关于这个问题的 YouTube 视频，那时我的频道全都是关于竞赛编程的。我记得我还为那些拿着弓箭的小火柴人制作了一个小图形，我想我还放了雷神托尔的动画
or clip art because I was a big fan of Thor Thor, God of Asgard. Anyways I don't even know what we were talking about you asked me to explain what do you mean by chewing? you're consuming a certain number of values, and if you have to do that repeatedly, you're going to end up with something.
or clip art because I was a big fan of Thor Thor, God of Asgard. Anyways I don't even know what we were talking about you asked me to explain what do you mean by chewing? you're consuming a certain number of values, and if you have to do that repeatedly, you're going to end up with something.|||或剪贴画，因为我是雷神托尔——阿斯加德之神的超级粉丝。总之，我甚至都不知道我们刚才在聊什么，你让我解释什么叫“嚼碎”？你是在消耗一定数量的值，如果你必须重复这样做，你最终就会得到某种结果。
Once again, Bryce is not doing a good job with the mic. He's got it in front of his mouth, and I'm the one talking. That is true. But anyways, you avoid a quadratic algorithm, and you end up with a linear plus scan and then repeated log N binary searches. Yeah. All right. What was the thing?
Once again, Bryce is not doing a good job with the mic. He's got it in front of his mouth, and I'm the one talking. That is true. But anyways, you avoid a quadratic algorithm, and you end up with a linear plus scan and then repeated log N binary searches. Yeah. All right. What was the thing?|||布莱斯又一次没有把麦克风用好。他把它举在自己嘴前，而说话的人是我。确实如此。但不管怎样，你避开了二次方复杂度的算法，最终得到的是一个线性的加法扫描，后面跟着重复的 log N 次二分查找。是的。好了。刚才那事是什么？
What was, what was the thing you wanted to talk about? The next topic. Wait, what, uh, what time are we at on our recording here? 30 minutes and four seconds.
What was, what was the thing you wanted to talk about? The next topic. Wait, what, uh, what time are we at on our recording here? 30 minutes and four seconds.|||你想聊的是什么来着？下一个话题。等等，我们现在的录音到哪个时间点了？30 分钟 04 秒。
Perfect folks. We just wrapped. We wrapped episode one of Slovenia 2023 road trip. We're still in Austria. Don't worry, Slovenia. We're coming. We're an hour and 16 minutes away from Lake Bled. My driving has been so fantastic.
Perfect folks. We just wrapped. We wrapped episode one of Slovenia 2023 road trip. We're still in Austria. Don't worry, Slovenia. We're coming. We're an hour and 16 minutes away from Lake Bled. My driving has been so fantastic.|||太完美了，各位。我们刚刚结束了。我们完成了 2023 年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行第一集的录制。我们还在奥地利。别担心，斯洛文尼亚。我们来了。我们距离布莱德湖还有一个小时十六分钟的车程。我的车技太棒了。
We've actually, we've increased our destination arrival time by one minute while we were recording that podcast. Probably shows you how great of a driver I am. What's the next topic? Okay, now we're at episode two. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to any of the things that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as to a GitHub discussion where you can ask questions, leave comments or thoughts. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
We've actually, we've increased our destination arrival time by one minute while we were recording that podcast. Probably shows you how great of a driver I am. What's the next topic? Okay, now we're at episode two. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to any of the things that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as to a GitHub discussion where you can ask questions, leave comments or thoughts. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||事实上，在我们录制那个播客期间，我们到达目的地的预计时间居然延长了一分钟。这大概能说明我的车技有多棒吧。下一个话题是什么？好了，现在我们进入第二集。请务必查看你的播客应用中的节目文稿（show notes）或访问 ADSP the podcast.com，获取我们在本期节目中提到的任何事物的链接，以及可以提问、留下评论或想法的 GitHub 讨论区链接。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。